how's it going on YouTube welcome to the
fourth episode of building your own
custom 3d playground we're gonna use
opengl gow3 visual studio to do so and
being that this is the fourth episode
we're a little further and now if you
haven't watched the previous three well
I guess I don't blame you but mostly
when I go through and those is how to
build libraries and how to attach the
libraries you need to visual studio so
being that it's been a while I'm gonna
go ahead and take it right from the
beginning and go from kind of the
nothing state all the way to rendering
some stuff on the screen if you want to
do this in a game engine like unreal or
Unity this might give some background
info as to how they may do some of their
things in those engines already but
really this is its own standalone thing
and not related to those game entrants
alright let's get into it
so first you need Visual Studio of
course I'm using video Visual Studio
community 24 free if you don't have it
already just find it through a google
search you'll get a Visual Studio
installer and and with that you can pick
which version you have installed you can
modify and launch so just real quick I
want to hit modify here to show you what
I got I just have the really basic stuff
the core desktop features and I have
this stuff - I'm not sure if I even need
any of it any of this other stuff so
I'll just scroll through it just in case
anybody needs to see it so let's make a
new project and we're gonna make it
empty empty C++ that's fine okay let's
go and we're gonna name this 3d
playground vid 4 so that's a very
specific name I realize but you know
keep it organized and now that we're in
here I'm gonna go ahead and change the
file view to show all files that way we
can see everything in our project and as
you can see here there is nothing in our
project it is completely blank blank so
we're going to
add a few folders first we're gonna
start with a new folder and we're just
gonna name this one SRC for source code
and I think that's all we're really
gonna need now no it won't need a few
more I'm gonna add include and I'm gonna
add library so just keep adding new
folders here because this is this is how
we're gonna include and link GL fw 3
which is our windowing system and we'll
add more things later as we need them
for like math and stuff but opengl
should already be all set up with your
video card okay so source let's add a
source file we just want a new item here
and we'll do it a CPP file I'm just
gonna call this main CDP so Visual
Studio handles all your setup for well
it handles all the build setup that's
one of the things that's nice about it
you don't have to manually configure
things with a make file or something it
just kind of sorts that out for you so
that's nice we're gonna go to release
and 64 so we're doing a 64-bit game we
released because we don't want so much
debugging info right now to convolute
stuff because if you build stuff for at
least 64 if you like you do all your
source and all your libraries and
linkers for a release and then later you
try to use the debug version the bugs
gonna the debug is gonna air out and say
look we don't have all the icons to
debug this thing you linked so yada yada
yada just keep it consistent basically
and if you want to know about more about
it Google is your friend there's a lot
of details online about the difference
between it release and debug now I feel
like I'm over explaining I'm gonna get
into it we're gonna add some includes
and libraries let's go ahead and get a
screen going you know excuse the
scatterbrained in this kind of just
winging it here but I hope it's helpful
we're gonna include well gow3 of course
it's not gonna find it
so we'll go link that real quick that's
really all we're gonna need there
all right so let's go link it I've
already got a built so all I've got to
do is just go get them off of my drive
here okay it looks like I have a folder
named dev on one of my drives and I got
GL fw3 here all ready to go so what I
did previously you can see in the
previous videos basically I built this
using C make and made sure it was
released 60 64 and for Visual Studio
2019 so what we're gonna need here is
the includes and we should have an area
where we built the library that's gonna
go in the library so that includes our
gonna go in the includes here and the
build libraries are going to go into the
libraries here let's start with the
includes alright so I think what we're
gonna have to do here is just navigate
to this location so if we right-click on
it and go to open folder and file
explorer we'll get to the include folder
that we made and we want to go back to
our other folder here and just drag or
we'll do a copy ctrl c ctrl c ctrl V and
just copy it over there and we're all
done there now we'll go into the build
and we're gonna look for the files we
built with what we're actually looking
for is dot live files it's gotta be in
source yeah looks like it builds it into
the source release and there it is so
let's copy that sucker and that should
be the one we need we'll go ahead and
paste that in there and now we've got
our include source files and our library
files in there so we can go ahead and
close this we'll stay here at this dev
in case we need to I'll just minimize
this one and now you see they haven't
shown up here yet we just have to hit
the refresh button and they will pop
right on up through they are and you
don't have to include them in your
project but what you do have to do is
tell your source files were to find all
your includes so the way you do that is
you just go to the top level your
project and right click and go to
properties you can also get to that same
thing through this project properties
and there's probably other ways too so
you want to go to the properties and
Mara with me a second let's uh if you
already know this because we did cover
in the previous videos I just want to be
all I just want to cover everything in
one video here that way nobody gets lost
so we go to the VCC directories here and
make sure we're on release in 64 and you
want to look for the include directories
and over way to the right there's a
little caret you click it and then click
Edit and you'll get a some lines here
and you basically just click on the line
and then click on these little three
dots and you highlight the folder that
is your include folder and hit select
and then you're pretty much done except
you can do the macro thing like I showed
in the first or second episode if you're
going to be working on this from
different computers the solution derp
thing you can instead of this whole
first section there's a macro for a
solution derp so that's gonna be the
same with the libraries here except
we're going to point to the libraries
folder and there we go and hit OK and ok
and another thing which we're gonna go
ahead and do is setup the linker for GL
fw 3 that way doesn't complain the first
time we compile so we go down to the
linker and open the carrot and the go to
input and you'll see additional
dependencies and you're just gonna click
on that and once again go to edit and
this time we're gonna add the name of
that library tlf w3 lime and it knows
where to find it because we told it
where the library files were right in
this folder and now it is also linked
and I also know just from experience
that we're gonna go ahead and need
OpenGL 32 dot live so we're gonna hit OK
on that as well and apply and now we've
got those two main things linked and
ready to go for when we program this all
up now we want to pop up our first
window with gow3 it still seems to be
complaining about not finding it that's
because I've typed a 3 here when there
is no 3 but otherwise it looks like the
header is correct don't use the native
one I don't know what the difference is
exactly but it's different so we'll hit
play here and just make sure nothing
crashes make sure there's no errors and
looks like it pops up a window
everything looks fine no build errors
but we're all
not doing anything yet so what we're
gonna go ahead and do is just go over to
GL fw3
on a Google search and look for the
window guide so if you do that if you
just do a search for the GL fw window
guide you'll find the latest and you'll
see some basic starting a window stuff
so we're going to click on window
creation here and it shows us a bit of
code looks like we're gonna need a
window we're gonna need to call this
create window and we're also gonna need
some other stuff so we'll go ahead and
do this create window go and then we
need to do a thing where we make our
window the current context I'm gonna
look for a block of code that has this
all included which should be I don't
know where it's at exactly somewhere on
there on their website here let's look
for the documentation and here we go
right on there first example code
they've got a thing of you setting up
the window initializing it creating it
Turman init terminating it if it fails
to create otherwise we're gonna make the
context current then we go into a while
loop where we show the window and do all
our double buffer stuff and at the end
of our program of course we terminate
you OFW and return 0 so yeah that's
perfect that's exactly what we want
we'll go over to here because we've got
the rest and we'll go back over here and
just paste that in get rid of this
original one here and this should be
enough see this deal clear right here is
a OpenGL call so we had to have the
OpenGL ready and linked and everything
else here is glf w3 g l 3 w 3 looks all
good so now what should happen is we
should get a window with the resolution
640 by 480 in the title hello world and
we'll go ahead and hit play here and
there's our little window doesn't do
anything yet we're using about 35
megabytes of memory to run our program
so far jail fw 3 does handle all the
resizing stuff so you can do the usual
stuff with your windows as your
operating system sees fit and as you can
see the memory changes as it is
literally usually more pixel space so
now what we want to do here is just make
a little
thing to render with OpenGL as you can
see with that window it is a certain
size now the way OpenGL does this it
translates the space of your window with
a zero zero in the center just like a XY
graph and it goes 0.5 th side
so right in the center is 0 0 x y 0 0
now if you go to the left all the way
and in the center you'll be at negative
0.5 X and to the right would be positive
0.5 X and at the top of course is the Y
with the positive being up and the
negative being down so it all works on a
one-to-one scale all the way across the
screen is one from top to bottom is 1
and that weighs the reserves that stays
in the middle that's how OpenGL thinks
of it so we can start actually rendering
pixels at with different colors at any
time using those coordinates as the
position that won't be very great for 3d
what you need to do to get it to be 3d
is have some kind of viewport or what
people usually call a camera class but
it is literally just the viewport of the
screen and then you warp it with matrix
math to make it look like you're in a
first-person world or whatever you want
to do and you translate your objects in
that space via the viewport and that's
where all the magic happens of rendering
cool stuff and getting cool lighting so
that's a very quick explanation of it
but let's go ahead and get a few pixels
rendering here because now the window is
working excellent as you can see and we
have done nothing really but set up our
project and just make sure a window pops
up in our main loop and just handles all
the very basics and needs to handle ok I
think we're just going to do this in
functions people often encapsulate this
sort of thing into a class but we are
just going to use a header
we'll just call a new item editor and
we'll call it
OpenGL pixel loader sure that works for
now that's an awful long name but in
this we can just build up our functions
and then include them in our main so
that we don't have to convolute our main
too much so we'll go ahead and include
spell include write or OpenGL pixel
loader here it doesn't have anything in
it yet but that's fine we will build
some stuff so we're gonna do a void load
of pixels and I will say load up square
and this is going to do some special
stuff where it pushes some points that
turn out to be a square to our graphics
card and we're gonna also have a unload
square whole square wrong this will just
remove it this is just going to remove
all our square data from the video card
if we request it that way we can clear
space for more objects so that's
something you kind of gotta need to know
if you're loading up models and stuff is
you want to know how to unload them and
actually purge the memory on the card
that's pretty important and we'll just
have a I guess just a render method and
it's just going to draw our set Square
and let's see what are we going to need
here let me think about this for a
minute I'll probably put another pause
right here okay I've just posted or
paste it in some stuff for loading up
cube it's basically a bunch of vertices
with positions normals and texture
coordinates it's a little overkill at
the moment I could probably get rid of
all these I'm just going to do positions
for the moment so I'm going to get rid
of all the extra stuff and as you can
see it just drawls at negative 5 to
positive 5 boundaries
and I've also noticed that none of these
calls seem to be recognized and the
problem there is we don't have our
OpenGL context linked usually people use
something like glue like Glu H but
there's also glad dot H and we can go
ahead and get glad it's basically
another thing that just grabs all the
OpenGL context and what you want to do
is just go to Google and look for glad C
OpenGL something like that something
like this glad C OpenGL and you will
find this website by David de who was an
excellent man who has helped a lot of
people with this header and basically
this just helps you link to the right
version of OpenGL and we're using plain
old GL here we're gonna go to the latest
version because I have a pretty recent
video card and it should support it and
yours probably should too unless you're
on a dinosaur but you can check that by
checking the details of your graphics
card if you are curious about exactly
what version you're on and I think I
went over that in the first or second
video so have a look there if you're not
sure but in general if you run a new
stuff 4.6 is fine these es versions are
for mobile stuff and you when you see a
bunch of extensions and we basically
just want everything we want the core so
I'm not sure how much this matters but
I'm gonna do core so OpenGL version two
point four point six core not gonna pick
anything specific we're gonna go ahead
and keep this generate Logar loader
there and we'll just click generate and
that will give us a link to a glads if
let's go ahead and download the zip so
we've now opened it and we can get out
of this website so you need that zip and
you want to just open the zip and
basically what we're gonna do is just
also put that in our includes and in our
library if need be let me move that off
for a second and I'm just going to do a
open folder and file explorer to get
back to my includes here and I see GL
fw3
so in here I also want to put in this
glad in K HR which is for Chronos in
here as well so I think my
zip we'll do it now it looks like it
brought the roof holder with it so I'm
gonna need to do a little correction
there because I don't want an include
folder within my include folder that's
confusing so we'll delete that after we
get those moved out and make sure
they're in there looking good we got
glad and we got that as well
okay very excellent let's take a look at
the source folder and see what we got we
got a glad see now this is needed in
your source folder as well I've just
happened to have the same name there so
that's neat yeah we're gonna go ahead
and bring this in I think it's going to
you know put it in our source here so
we'll hit this refresh button now that
we've included those and we'll see a few
new things pop up
there's glad there's the khr we're not
necessarily gonna use this k chart but i
don't wanted to go ahead and link it
just in case it comes in handy so
there's a glad see we want to make sure
this compiles so we're gonna go ahead
and right-click it and do an include in
project so whatever folder it's in
doesn't really matter that much I am
actually think I'm gonna drop it into
this include folder here and I get some
error but it's probably just that Visual
Studio hadn't made its correction right
away but it is still included in the
project so it should still build and now
what we do we just hit save on
everything when we go back to our OpenGL
pixel loader and we see that GLAAD is
here we also need to make sure we go
into the gladdened folder and then yes
glad H very good so now it is linked and
it will build and this should now be
pretty happy about these functions to GL
since we have the the thing that
references them all there so that's all
well and good now as you can see here I
have some variables that I copied over
that aren't instantiated I have a VA oh
and a VB oh now one of the things we're
gonna need is we're gonna need to save
this VA oh because well if you're
rendering a bunch of different objects
you have to switch to which one you're
rendering before calling all your render
calls so what we're gonna do here is
we're just gonna take this cube Bao and
we're going to make a global for now
this is not necessarily a good idea I
usually want this encapsulated somewhere
of an unsigned and
cube Bao and we'll just set that to zero
oopsie if I can type and we're gonna
make sure that this is a static so that
it doesn't change we just want to make
sure there's only one cube Bao and if
you're wondering why our drat our
background is black it's because we're
using this GL color buffer bit and it is
probably set to all-black by default so
you can actually change this color
buffer bit to something else if you want
a different colored screen by default
all right so now we've got the cube a
Bao it seems to be happy about that and
it once a cube VBO as well now this
references which array in the VA oh so
the VA Oh is like it's a stack of VB
o--'s basically so we'll take this vbo
and we'll just instantiate it somewhere
and we'll go ahead and just make it in
unsigned int up here and I guess we can
have it be static that's fine we just
don't want ever more than one of them at
the moment and there we go now it seems
to be happy so what this is gonna do is
of course we're gonna declare an array
of floats called vertices and it's just
a bunch of positions so this is a bunch
of points these are XYZ now without a
viewport the Z doesn't make much sense
because it goes away from you and at the
same with it being positive doesn't make
a whole lot of sense close just comes
towards you so you need a viewport to
really see the difference between those
may just come at these rafters we're not
using them basically these are pointing
to a shader typically so the the first
array is 0 so we're enabling the very
first one and we just need to tell it
that it is this data of the vertices and
we've got everything set up here for it
to do its thing there's one thing that's
a little different here because we
corrected this they used to have 8
different points per set of data now it
only has 3 so this is no longer times 3
boats of width it's only or it's no
longer times 8 is only times 3 floats of
width and it's the very first one so
it's void 0 but this is basically where
at and your data so you basically always
want to be using in buffering your data
and a race like this that way you can
calculate where at in memory to send to
it and we'll go ahead and comment out
this line actually it will leave it here
just so it will say cube load at the
graphics card and we'll go ahead and
include the iostream so that message can
work and at the end we're going to bind
vertex array to 0 so it's up to the
render call to rebind the right vertex
array before rendering and that's going
to look a little something like like
this so when we're ready to draw this
cube that we loaded up we bind the vieo
that's the very top level 1 and then we
enable the attribute array which is the
vbo thing and it's the very first one so
it's just 0 that's where it index is in
basically and then we want to draw
arrays and we're going to draw with
triangles and this is 0 to 36 because
there are 36 and then when we're all
done doing this draw we want to set the
vertex array back to 0 so there doesn't
mess up any later calls so that's how
you render so if we call these functions
it might be enough to work let's double
check so we're gonna call load up square
before we get to this while loop so
we'll do that right here load up square
that should push it to the graphics card
and then we're gonna call render write
about before the swap buffer so we got
to do the clear first then we do our
rendering and that renders on to the
back buffer so you got to do a swap and
that will bring what whatever you last
rendered to the screen so it'll key and
then it'll pull four events from the
keyboard
that's a jill jill fw thing and it'll
render these uh points now i think it's
a black screen and i think it's going to
be a white cube let's see
we're not getting much okay what I need
to do here is I need to include Geo glad
before GL fw3 so that's a little
confusing that's a little obscure okay
now I think that will resolve it let's
go ahead and just do a rebuild yes so
you have to include glad before gow3 one
succeeded we're looking good here and
we'll go ahead and run what we got and
we shouldn't really see too much
oh no we see everything fine okay so
this is our first square or our first
cube that we loaded to the graphics card
and it seems to be rendering and just
fine okay so hopefully I can cut this
together in a way that makes sense to
everybody
but that little glad thing needed to be
before GL fw3 really tripped me up for a
minute
basically what happens is you get a
default shader that does very basic
things only and there's probably more
info about that but it just colors your
pixels white it looks like to start out
with so in our main we've got it all set
up we don't ignore the shader thing
we'll get into that next episode because
we will start having to pass in the view
matrix to the shader so that it knows
how to render our box and do more of a
square version all right we've got
something rendering to the screen and
hopefully this helps you guys out some
and well I guess I also didn't want to
show you how to unload the square from
the video card when you're done so let
me just find that I think it is it's one
of these it's like I'll remove buffer
it's like GL delete buffer delete
buffers and then I think the size is
gonna be the same as whenever we started
out as and then it's just gonna be that
cubed there's a chance I'm doing this
slightly wrong so maybe you can correct
me on that if you learn better but this
delete basically you want to remove the
the stuff in the buffers alright thanks
for checking out this episode I hope you
guys were able to get your little square
rendering on screen I'll try to do a new
one scene soon a new episode soon and
I'll pick up a right where I left off
we'll get the viewport going and we'll
start doing some some little 3d stuff
I'm trying to figure out the best way to
get support on this channel so anything
you do helps a lot if you're watching
this video thank you very much if you
give it a like thank you even more
[Music]